ciao solita storia
oggi nuova challenge ieri siamo stati
data ieri abbiamo fatto un po di
shopping che abbiamo anche trovato cosa
molto particolare interesse delle mani
in miniatura e pensate se proviamo a
fare lo slime con le mani in via turati
già sparito vince chi fa lo slime più
bello è anche chi fa il booking più
bello con le bussani mia ho fatto che
adesso ha detto questo processo sia io
non so perché mi fa impressione
io ho cambiato magliette abbassano
sempre team azzurro vediamo telethon
band chievo deve far prendere la paletta
di miss car colombo ordine dei giochi
android in bici vittima consorziale
quando si guardano le direttamente così
con le macchine siano prende gli
ingredienti siamo proprio così come toni
in salita e non facciamo cazzate occhio
ordinaria ma di mettere le mani nei
capelli non sono più mistico in
questione sembra che vuoi piccoli con 56
mettiamo allora con la possibile prima e
come si fa ad aprire fatto dell'incastro
va in mezzo alle divinità azzurro
vitality imberbe si no
da tu la devi tenere bassa io devo stare
anche senza severe fatta lasciamolo
godeva la casa io volevo approfittare
anche aiutato non è vero
vabbè che come facciamo il vicino amici
camilli ma che non sarebbe si chiama
pazzo addio
secondo sì perché troppo forte tutto a
posto a ben terna porta allora hai visto
di aiutato sono stato bravo ad avitare
non scende come non scendete a tornare
poco dopo lo 0 2 e scivolando no no
l'olio di insieme ancora ma vicino
lasciato la mia così le metto gruppo
nella mia ma tuttavia anche i toni visto
aiutando di aggravando di ora
[Musica]
[Applauso]
signor sindaco ci fossimo scivola ci si
deve credere mettere il tappo niente
fosse è la classica sono troppo forte
bravissimo ok allora il primo tempo
dalla colla è fatto miracolosamente ci
siamo riusciti adesso ora adesso
colorante abbiamo provato è possibile
occorre ancora runkle coloranti è quello
lei questo tubero
io sono stato allora presidi bene dice
ci facciamo mettere quelli che sono
quelli grandi secondo me io quelle
grandi che hanno messo consigliato parte
di piccole più facile io però non per i
piccoli vediamo viola ridiamo lo sai che
non sarei mai si è sto cercando di
dargli un porto per obbligo non è facile
niente come facciamo cosa mi diano
lasciamo bianco io ti senti chi parla
ora che cada tutto lo sono stato io
dopotutto è notato qualcosa per te vi
aiuto io sono rigide a mettere le
palline nello slam ora promette
restituite le argentati delle palline
dopo aiuto
ora spetta a chi malabarba stai facendo
qualche mostra di kung fu così favorire
questo colpo di grazia forza
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mi ha dato un po no sporcato le vuol
dire come sporcato le mani ne posso non
posso aggiungere altro ha portato la
felpa a quello che facciamo un mini
mescoliamo che sto già mescolando il
collant allora i quali criteri delle mie
manine vi è un mestiere mi disse che non
si colora anche però penso che si va
bene lo stesso perché sia la schiuma da
barba le palline almeno ce l'ha dentro
dall'angolo quella cosa lì
[Musica]
ho dato io sono anche soluzione per
lenti
anzi di caccia dobbiamo stare attenti
inventerebbe poco
chiara è sporcato da dammi un po di
bicarbonato da qui mancava da qui è
perché sono troppo non per sempre quel
lavoro di squadra devo dire che ci
stiamo riuscendo e quindi dovete
aiutarmi a dovete votare me non sempre
d'unità che votando a tutti quando bubi
combattere conoscendo il macello che
ragazzi siamo quasi il mio quasi pronto
per quasi pronto a fare pochi in difetto
cioè praticamente è pronto sistemi
maniche sono più per supporre che però è
pronto perché troppo verde più bardolino
i nas hanno anche ti ho messo tutto a me
peggio per te che mi hai fatto non
perfetta io devo può attivare il fondo
rotativo di mele però sto raccogliendo
le brevi qui
[Musica]
io ho un pochino sociali siamo pronti
alla sfida a chi vincerà aimi da evitare
terra ecco allora si mostrava forma
dovere con queste mani comunque è
rimasto bianca non è diventato verde per
fortuna è un bel po klaxons e di potere
star tirarlo su fini abbastanza
estensibile vediamo che sony fa a che
pro click e incredibile che può king
non riesco a fare lo studio tu stai dall
addio chiamare così pensate che botta di
dati da 1 a 10 vediamo proprio a
spalmarlo mostrava la cosa mi faccio un
passaggio devi allora primo limitare col
vivo è un po bertolino è un po bertolino
perché qualcuno mi ha aggiunto alberto
che l'europa liberale youtube
io comincio subito con il proprio
silenzio sono imposto parte con gli
anatemi
beh mi sa che vinco io in pochi anzi
guarda un po e si insedia il booking con
le mani di temi come mori bene e questo
il bio on line un po bertolino però
rimane sul verso ufficio è super
modellabile non dico che è molto
allungati le marche che ha avuto tutto e
può dire vikarby campo dalla rosa e si
allunga abbastanza bene meglio del tuo
sicuramente per essere fatto tutto con
le mani né domani né mai si allungano ma
ci sono tante e addio ieri di quella che
non sei ettari bianca che hai fatto
almeno fosforescente perderlo storiche
più belle vue quale quale prove hanno
votate
votata equa soft dove state votate qua
sopra
qual è lo slide bello qui vi lascio il
link votate per momenti di vita densa la
vita le diverse giochi bello ma guardate
quanto è bello veramente che viviamo c'è
paragone perché dove deve andare con i
popoli
ma dove deve andare dove devo andare
questo è più bello che bello che questa
cosa qui che cos'è che scansa che questa
cosa così il suo il sacco a pelo o molto
più bello il mio guardate facendo che de
mello bello fra fosse il derby
bellissimo papà di commerciare aumentata
a pagare il viaggio che strano di certo
non lo fai mai bene
allora votate che sei mio vince il mio o
quello digitale
prima mi ha guardato il capo dello stato
lasciato bella i caldissimi la rice
andremo a rifarla aggiungendo qualcosa
che voi per chi votate
fatemi sapere che ha votate verde nei
commenti e andremo a rifare la challenge
e magari facendo con le manine è in
silenzio quindi provando con le manine
oppure scopriamo quali non scrivete cima
nei commenti consigliateci piana 3
challenge fare e ora vi lasciamo qua 4
cappellino e su cui cliccare per vedere
inoltre altri video video divertenti
challenge con la ruota slide complicato
di quello che preferiva nel finale